NARRATOR: Andros Island,
the Bahamas, 2003.
Members of the Association
for Research and Enlightenment
conduct aerial searches
for underwater structures
that might reveal evidence
of a lost civilization.
Off of the coast
of Andros, they
discovered an
incredible platform
of rectangular and square
stones that stretched
for several hundred yards.
And all the indications
are that it goes back
to the end of the last ice
age and is probably around
11,000 to 12,000 years old.
NARRATOR: The search is
part of a long-term project
working in conjunction
with the Cayce Foundation.
Their quest is to locate
remnants of the lost continent
of Atlantis, which healer
and psychic Edgar Cayce
said would be
located in the area.
DAVID WILCOCK: Edgar
Cayce is arguably
America's greatest psychic.
He was born in
1877, died in 1945.
And he has documented over
14,000 psychic readings.
What's interesting is
that Cayce also got
into things like reincarnation.
Some of Cayce's
clients were told
that they had lifetimes in the
so-called mythical civilization
of Atlantis.
In fact, Cayce's readings said
that the people of Atlantis,
as a whole, had
mass reincarnated
as the people of America, and
that America was, in a sense,
a future life
carryover of Atlantis.
NARRATOR: Cayce revealed
in his psychic readings
that the truth about the nature
of this lost civilization
exists in a hidden
hall of records
at three locations
across the globe--
in Egypt, near the Sphinx;
underwater in the Bahamas;
and in the Yucatan Peninsula.
Any three of these
areas apparently
would have all of the
records that we would need
to completely
rebuild our history
and understand
how there may have
been much more widespread
extraterrestrial presence here
on Earth.
NARRATOR: Could recent
archaeological finds
in the Bahamas confirm
that Edgar Cayce was
right about the
existence of a lost
extraterrestrial civilization?
And if so, should we be
concerned about his predictions
for the future of humanity?
Cayce was a cataclysmist.
And in his readings,
he was constantly
talking about Earth
changes and pole
shifts that caused
civilizations to be
destroyed in ancient times.
And Cayce said
that we were going
to have another pole
shift around the time
of the millennium.
Even a relatively
small asteroid
coming in at the right angle--
not necessarily hitting
Earth, but grazing the Earth--
could theoretically change
the tilt axis of the Earth
significantly.
Now, if that occurred,
land and ocean would
redistribute on the Earth.
WILLIAM HENRY: It seems as
if history repeats itself.
And it may be that,
at this moment,
we are exactly in
the same situation
that the citizens
of Atlantis were in.
ANDREW COLLINS: Perhaps we
will find out exactly what had
happened to this
lost civilization
and learn from their mistakes
and not sink into oblivion
ourselves.
GIORGIO A. TSOUKALOS:
The more we uncover,
it will all point
in one direction.
We are not the first,
and we never have been.
An extraterrestrial
pre-civilization existed
before our recorded history.
And this truth will be
revealed within our lifetime.
NARRATOR: Could the
stories of a time when
gods and other worldly
beings inhabited the Earth
be more than just mythology?
And might the discovery
of unexplainable remnants
from this lost civilization
reveal the truth
about our
extraterrestrial origins,
as ancient astronaut
theorists suggest?
Perhaps we are on the verge
of uncovering the final piece
of the puzzle that will
change our understanding
of Earth's history forever.
But will we uncover it
before it's too late?
[otherworldly explosion]